so wait before you got the show scandal
you did a lot of private was it catering
gigs oh yeah i had every job um but yes
i catered a lot i catered you know hugh
jackman's super bowl party or every
sunday night dinner at courtney cox's
house with jennifer aniston and all
these people it was so yes it was was it
intimidating or was it like were they
always like first everybody was actually
cool and
you know what it was such a hollywood
story i used to come home with people
like are you making it yet like did you
book a job like no but i cleaned your
dishes whatever it's fine but you know
what's really weird
you know when you meet people would
always ask me which celebrities have you
met what men and i'd say like oh yeah
i've seen justin timberlake i've seen
brad pitt i've seen all these guys and
really they didn't
do it for me except one guy
i was hosting it was me
because i didn't know you had stuff for
one guy
i know it's crazy i'm at my host stan
motorcycle pulls up
helmet comes off okay it's a slow-mo
hair situation my knees start shaking
i'm having real reaction to like a
celebrity like i like how i feel about
you and then
and and he slowly walks up and he's like
a male triangle like perfectly shaped
and it's
keanu reeves oh yeah we have him on it
he's so nice
well what i've heard is that he's the
knight off he's also like the nicest
human ever this is what i'm kind of i
would like to pat myself on the back
that i really i have a good radar for a
good guy his soul his soul
he is so kind i love the whole set up
though arriving on a motorcycle right
here in the wings like what i hear the
catering of this party is amazing
he was just like you know reeves you
know the reservation i'm like
on let me just like take you to your
table you can follow me this way
did y'all ever have a situation like
before you had made it with the
celebrity did you ever have anything an
encounter yeah you know i had a speaking
of aniston when we were doing the
horrible bosses movies she invited god
that was so funny a party at her house
and my wife was like we should bring
like a bottle of wine and be polite but
i was like this is like this was like a
written invitation like this i think
this is a big party i think they're
gonna have catering um and i was like
well i don't know if we should bring a
bottle of wine and so merlin says i'm
bringing a bottle of wine she brings it
in we walk in the door the first person
i see is tom cruise
ellen
and just like gotta put the bottle back
in the first
throw it into the question like an okay
bottle i mean it was like nice but not
oh yeah no who's like like a eight
dollar bottle of wine
[Applause]
this is just for you jen
we got this at roush
[Music]
you